does this cause you think depression in  law women where they struggle between a  career having kids they're kind of like  what should i do  in your opinion  i mean probably it's one of the like  main concerns and i know a lot of women  who like put it off because the media  also tells you that you can have kids  until you're like you're ah don't worry  you're like 35 or 38 look at this  celebrity you had a kid when she's 40.  yeah and then i know people who are even  mid-30s and couldn't have kids or a  little bit younger than that and they're  like what like i've been told a lie yeah  so that's one of the biggest lies we  tell women is they can put off that is  and that is  a catastrophe yeah because like you're  missing out on one of the reasons people  are people  right that's crazy